my name is cha-cha merlot i do data
analysis work for a company called Booz
Allen Hamilton and I have a kind of a
programming school that I run called the
dark art of coding today we're gonna
talk a little bit about using dates and
times in the pandas library and in kind
of python generically this material is a
material that i put together for the
university of hawaii where i teach some
data analysis things right all right I
will say that unfortunately you know for
those who might have stepped in the room
wanting to hear the - talk Chris was
unable to make it so I am a I'm your
last-minute fill-in right so sorry -
sorry to disappoint but we'll talk about
dates and times how python handles those
and we'll talk about how using dates and
times in pandas can make your life
simpler and easier and more efficient
and effective
all right that's kind of the objective
as is normal with kind of any kind of
conversation about pandas we're going to
kind of do some imports of different
components that we might use so we'll
import pandas as PD all that right as we
get into this I have to spend a little
bit of time just on date/time objects
generically so that way we have in our
heads kind of this this background
scenario of what we're actually playing
with when we talk about date/time
objects
the nuance here is kind of highlighted
in bold daytime objects are not strings
of individual text they're not strings
of characters right they are actually
Python objects and they have
characteristics associated with them
they have metadata associated with them
etc all right so for starters I'm going
to import from the date/time module
date/time function and a time delta
function and I'm gonna start off by
making a very simple date/time object
and let's see then I'm going to ask
Python to show me what this date/time
object looks
like and tell me what type of thing it
is using the print statement right and
the type function over here alright and
we see that looks like a string your
2016 - month day the object is a
date/time date/time object right so this
is actual some sort of Python thing it
is not simply a sequence of characters
right
alright when you ask pandas to display
this object to the screen as an output
instead of simply printing it you'll see
that it highlights a couple of things
it's got a date/time date/time object
and then it has three numbers and then
two zeros by default it stores a year a
month a day an hour in a minute because
I did not provide it originally with any
sort of hours of minutes it just
automatically defaulted to zero all
right now in pi/3 paterno books right
you want to know more about certain
things that you've created you can ask
questions using the question indicator
and it'll tell you look the default
minimum you have to put in to create a
date/time object is the year month and
day and then it identifies that you can
go all the way down to microseconds you
can also include a timezone information
and all those will come into play when
we start looking at pandas all right
so we'll close out that little help
there okay I'm going to now create two
more date/time objects I'm going to put
the hours of 12 and the hours of 11 into
these and then we're going to do a
subtraction just see what we get
no big deal all right and I'm gonna ask
Python again show me what we've got and
show me what type of object it is and we
see that we've created a time delta
object and we see that there's simply an
hour's worth of difference between the
two if I look at the difference object
inherently we see that it gives me back
to zero and 3600 all right I would have
expected maybe an hour or something like
that
so when I first ran across this I was a
little confused I said hey tell me a
little bit more about time Delta why did
I get that and when I looked at the help
there was not a whole lot of usefulness
there and then I went and looked at the
source code by using two question marks
and it came across the coolest comment
I've ever found
so we scroll down kind of looking at
things and it says that representation
is days seconds and microseconds and he
said why because I felt like it all
right so that's good all right so that's
your comic relief we're done okay so
let's talk about these date/time objects
when we store information as a date/time
object we can get to that information
fairly intuitive I just said that I've
created a difference object between two
time stamps how many days of difference
are there or how many days seconds of
difference are there and I can ask for
that well there was zero days difference
and there's 3,600 seconds worth of
difference and you can do that with any
day time object or any time dealt
objects you can start to dive into it
show me what the week was show me what
the hour was those kinds of things so
for example if I look at date three and
I want to look at our day month year I
can get access to all of those things
and so it was to do you know 11th hour
the third day fifth month and the year
2016 if you're curious and you want to
know what are all the other options that
you have available to you you just use
2ab completion and you start to see that
you can get to a wide variety of things
the day of the week you can get it in
various formats whether it's
International formats etc you can
identify seconds and we're gonna look at
a couple of these functions you can
actually change the default outputs and
you can set mechanisms to read data in
in particular ways we're not going to go
through all of these but they're there
there's a lot of power associated with
daytime objects and pandas takes
advantage of just about all of that
all right for a situational awareness
when you print out a string you are you
a date/time object and when displayed to
the screen it has to default
representations one of them is what we
call the string representation and one
of them is an ISO representation and
we'll take a quick look at how that
differs so one of them basically has a
big T in the middle and one of them
doesn't all right
but using stiff time you'll see in a few
minutes we can set how that looks we
don't have to use either these two
defaults if we're reading in some sort
of weird a time stamp that some guy has
pulled together and it's in some odd
format we can set our parser to accept a
variety of odd parsing okay so for
example I have a date/time object I'm
about to make year 2009 September
September 9th and I want it to display
with years months days and hyphens in
between them I can use sturm to display
that and we get this with hyphens if I
want to put other things in there you
know put lots of hyphens just because
I'm that way you can put lots of hyphens
and you can put you know Python right
whatever you can format these however
you'd like okay let's see you might ask
yourself well what is this parentheses
why parentheses em those are formatting
specifications and there is a huge
collection of them I'm going to try and
pull this up in another another tab okay
and see if we can blow this up a little
bit and all right apologize if this is
kind of small font this is what you get
when you're real speaker gets injured
okay so you have these these percent
specifications and you can now identify
how you would like the year to show up
or how you would like the month to show
up etc and they have lots of different
options right you can say for example
month if I put a percent B should show
up as a full word it should show up as
January or February if my computer is
set to use a particular locale say I'm
living in Germany it would then use the
German locale spelling for those
particular months jeonhwa februar
alright those kinds of things
if you want your month formatted with
zero padding in the beginning so it's a
zero one zero two they have all these
options I'm not going to go through all
of them that's an exercise for the
student right but there's lots and lots
of these formatting specifications that
are available to you to help you kind of
identify how you'd like your format's to
look and all that stuff kind of rolls
right into what you can do with pandas a
couple things I haven't confirmed this
but I've heard that the supported
formatting codes vary across platforms
mostly because Python relies on an
underlying C library ster function but
as it says on the screen right it
apparently uses all the formatting codes
from the 1989 version and they should be
consistent but certain libraries will
give you a few extra formatting codes
all right
so string parsing say your data source
gives you data in some really bizarre
format and they chose some really
ignorant method for formatting the dates
and times right well you can get around
that if you know what the date-time
format should be you can identify that
using these formatting specifications so
percent m to say this first number
should be interpreted as a month percent
D to say the second number should be
interpreted as a day etc all right and
so when we run that sure enough it
interpreted you know these things the
way we want so let's make this let's see
the day make it one all right so it's
able to correctly interpret that the one
should fall in the dates place all right
so well manually setting your formatting
will work for you for heavy-duty
date/time parsing there's an automatic
parser available in the date util
library and it's pretty hard to beat
I'll give you an example so I pull in
the date util parser
and I import parse I give it three
samples of dates the first one is pretty
straightforward
the year 2000 the month January the day
the first but then the second one I
throw a little a little bit of walking
us in there I'm going to put a random
comma gonna put in an hour and a minute
the last one I throw in some really
bizarre things I'm gonna put the date
first I'll put that Ardi in there that
people's at the 23rd and Lord willing
this date you till parser will grant
grok all of that and hook me up right so
all right and sure enough we look at the
first version it successfully parses out
let me shrink that down where'd it go it
successfully parses out the dates and
the fact that we had things like the
23rd doesn't phase date you till date
you till is used essentially in the
background by pandas to do your date
parsing for you so you don't even have
to fuss with it and so when you get
really weird dates in your in your data
the date to util library in most cases
can handle kind of these things
generically and automatically for us all
right so let's get to the meat of the
matter let's talk a little bit about
pandas all right
I've got a CSV it's one that I generally
threw together I think it's got ten
lines in it it has about eight columns
give or take the first one is somebody's
name the second one is somebody's email
address a from IP a to IP a date/time
module a latitude or longitude and the
payload size again this is all fake
random data
I think there's superheroes in here but
the important part when you use for
example the library or that the the
function read CSV you can tell it that
you would like to use a particular
column to be your index and so I'm going
to tell it use whatever you find in the
date/time column to be my index and then
I'm going to tell it parse those strings
as dates and it pulls the date time or
date utils parser out
and it does it's parsing for you and
tries to make these into date/time
objects pandas style date/time objects
so let's give this a whirl fingers
crossed and sure enough on the far left
side we have date/time is used as my
index it does not show up anywhere in a
column right so now my index for a time
series of data is date/time objects
right okay so what does that mean
starters to kind of look at some of this
data I'm just gonna grab one column I
want to see one of the columns
it's the names column notice each of
those items has got its index they're
all date/time objects so we got Barry
Allen and those folks if I want to look
at that index and see what type of an
object it is what did pandas make for me
I can ask and I'll say it is a date/time
index so it's a very special style of
index has slightly different
capabilities and we get to see all of
the entries that are found in the index
something to note it says date/time 64
NS down at the bottom
pandas has the capability to handle date
times all the way down to nanoseconds
whereas the date/time module handled
them down to microseconds alright so
this gives you a lot of flexibility
especially in things where stuff's
moving quickly alright if you need to
grab a particular item out of that index
I've created a time stamp index and just
say I want the fifth thing for example
and it will find the fifth object of
course panda is in Python index by zero
now if you are looking at a series or
maybe at a data frame and you want to
grab out data in a particular row well
you could do something like this you
could say hey let me tell you what data
is found in that index and then give me
back that information and so we get the
data from that one row Arthur curry
that's the minimum that one would expect
but that's not the minimum that pandas
offers so let's take a look at that
I asked for a very specific sequence of
items I wanted 2016 all the way down to
2 seconds but I don't have to be that
specific I can simply say hey pandas
show me all the stuff that has the year
2016 the month February in the day six
and now it goes and grabs all those
things and I didn't have to do anything
crazy or bizarre it automatically read
that parsed it as and if a date/time
object compared it to the index that I
had and voila I'm gonna make a new data
frame this is going to be a few more
records but it's essentially going to be
the same type of data there'll be a
thousand records here that'll give us a
chance to play a little more effectively
and look at a few more things so read
that in fingers crossed okay and this
particular data set again looks nearly
identical instead of asking for one row
I would like to see this data frame but
I want to see all the records in this
data frame with the Year 2015
notice all of those indexes are these
long sequences of characters but I just
have to put in 215 and it gets every one
of those things from the records right
and there's about 700 of these records I
think 742 if I want September 2015 I
asked for September 2015 a note I typed
the word September I don't have to type
in 2015 - 9 I type in September and the
date you told parser in the background
does the things that it does all right
and it gives me 181 records I'm a little
person tickity I want to test this I
want to see how well this thing works so
let's just ask for the 31st of October
in the year 2015 we throw in the st we
throw in the comma and yeah it gives me
9 records from October 31st right so
your ability to grab data in an
intuitive fashion through pandas and
what it has under the hood is is quite
nice all right if you want data from one
point to another point you can do a
slice in pandas here again
October 29 to October 31st
but again I'm persnickety right see if
we can break this thing
I threw the comma in the wrong place
nobody puts the comma after October they
put it after the 29 and sure enough it
still gives me what I expect right so
again a lot of good power even if you
kind of mess things up all right
pandas has the ability to allow you to
create functions that you could apply to
things if you'd like so in this case I'm
gonna create a random function that I
made it just looks at ISO format date
time stamps finds that little T that's
in the middle and splits the data in
half just for kicks so I did my
conversion by applying my date split
function to the column date time and
then I told it to go ahead and parse the
dates and then we're just gonna look at
it all right so now all I have left for
my date time stamps are these years
right I purposely kind of filtered out
all the the minutes and stuff for some
of the analysis we're gonna we're gonna
do next all right so I've just got years
months days random guys okay let's group
by and we'll group by level zero in
terms of the hierarchy let's take a look
at the size of the various groups that
we've created in pandas we see that
things that occurred on September 4th
there was only two records there on
September 9th there was 11 records ok
and so with these day time stamps as
parts of your indexes you can now use
regular pandas tools to kind of group
things conveniently so you can start to
see what are the trends do we see that
more things occur on weekends or do we
see that more things occur on weekdays
that kind of thing all right
sometimes your data comes in kind of
lumping Zoar groupings that you're not
real happy with or maybe you want to
kind of aggregate your data in certain
ways the date/time capability spans
allow you to resample your data in
particular ways so I created a make sure
I got this right
created a data frame it's the same one
we looked at a minute ago but now I want
to resample it I want to resample it
down to just things that happen in 2-day
increments so all of the records that
happened for example maybe on the first
and second should all be lumped together
as something that happened on the first
day all the things that happened on the
third and fourth should be lumped into
something that happens on the third so
let's take a look at this kind of
resampling to see what we got
excellent this is what you get when you
have live demos all right make sure you
got all these things here all right so
we're gonna skip that moving on
okay so pandas changes how they do
things under the hood periodically I
can't remember when I wrote this content
I have this sneaking suspicion that
something changed under the hood and
changed in just enough time to embarrass
me in front of a group full of my
friends and peers and people that I
don't know and folks that I'm gonna see
on YouTube decades from now okay so we
talked about resampling what we should
have seen was all the things that
happened on the first and second got
lumped together essentially it's a group
by the ability to do this resampling is
pretty sophisticated so for example if I
put a to capital M I could regroup or I
could resample by every two months so
all the stuff that happened in January
and February all gets lumped together if
I want to do my reasoning on a daily
basis everything that happens between
12:01 and 11:59 essentially gets lumped
together that's cool but it gets even
more powerful in that if I type 2h30
mi n it'll resample by every 2 hours and
30 minutes
the resampling specification is in
the help menu and it gives you lots of
options and lots of options means lots
of options like if I care about
resampling on a business day Monday
through Friday
right it allows you the opportunity to
use business days business months
calendar months and it gives you the
opportunity to do things like set when
your business Week starts or when your
Week starts My Week starts on a Sunday
but your week and your country might
start on a Monday those kinds of things
and so you can calibrate how you
resample there's too much to go into
here but just know that that capability
is available to you all right
so let's talk a little bit about time
stamps I had a data frame that we read
in earlier I had a thousand records in
it we're just going to look at a couple
of records right now like maybe the top
ten rows I think something like that all
right I'm gonna ask it to show me what
the time zone is associated with this
index and so we scroll down and we see
that there is no time zone currently
associated with this when I read in the
data frame I didn't tell it what time
zone to consider but we can fix that I
can take this little data frame that
I've made and I can say let's localize
this so these records are indicative of
something that occurred in the US and
the eastern time zone so run that and
[Music]
this is totally not liking me Oh shucks
let's take a look this first time zone
this time stamp was set to be twenty one
forty four minutes right so 21 hours
forty four minutes I then tell it that
this should be characterized as being in
the eastern time zone and Lord willing
when I convert the time zone from us
Eastern to us Hawaii we now see that all
the time stamps go from 949 952 about
sixteen forty four four o'clock in the
afternoon for forty five right so in
this first case I set the time zone the
data came in as eastern us it all said
944 I convert the time zone from Eastern
to Hawaii and the time stamps show up as
four o'clock all right sweet something
to note the date/time libraries are
smart enough to know about daylight
savings time and those kinds of things
in the month of February the difference
between Eastern and Hawaii is five hours
in the middle of the summer the
difference is six hours so because this
occurred in February it was smart enough
to say your offset should only be five
hours so when I did that conversion it
knew what to do and what to expect
alright let's see let's talk a little
bit about periodicity this is not a
thing that I use often so I don't have a
whole lot of nuances in need to
for this but I figure I should mention
it because it's it's available to folks
who would use periodicity in their data
all right okay you can create periods of
time within pandas in this case I would
like to create a period of time and we
tell it that the period should be a week
long it should be 2015 so it finds a
period of time that started on a Monday
that is as close as possible to the
beginning of the year 2015 so it found
something that started in 2014 on the
30th of December and created a single
period all right so it's a single
timespan if I need to have periodicity
that extends across a longer period I'm
you can pick create period ranges and so
you tell it when to start and when to
end and you can tell it what your
frequency is these periods should be a
quarterly period they should be a weekly
and monthly daily business daily those
kinds of things
and so let's create a period of values
and so it starts in October or it starts
in 2010 and it goes for the last quarter
which includes December and then it
keeps going all the way up to 2015
everything that includes December
alright if you want to convert a period
make it a slightly different periodicity
you can do that so I'm going to convert
that first period that we had would had
a frequency of weekly starting on Monday
I want to convert that and set it tell
it that it should start and it uses this
default starting date of Sunday instead
of the Monday I had previously picked
and noticed that the start dates and end
dates have now shifted over by one if
you want to convert an entire sequence
of periods this period range you can do
that tell it what frequency you want I
want a daily frequency now gives me the
first of the
first of the quarter the second quarter
third quarter right and let's go look at
one of my data frames I want to convert
the periodicity of one of my data frames
to be a monthly periodicity instead of
all those random times that we had and
so now we see that all the things that
might have occurred some randomly in a
month these are all showing up within
particular months it's a similar concept
to resampling different nuances though
alright next there's a lot of stuff
there due to if we want to convert
date/time back to timestamps one thing
that you should know when you're doing
lots of reasoning is if you sample to
something that is very generic and try
and work your way back to specificity so
we convert maybe two months now we
convert back two days we lose all of
those days when we down convert right so
this will have to default back to some
generic day of the month and so all
these things that have gotten sorted out
to fit into February we need to apply a
day to them and it won't know what to do
so to default to probably the first of
the month let's take a look see we get
and so all these things that were in
February are now unfortunately kind of
dumped onto February 1st so be real
careful when you're resampling and
you're changing periodicity x' and those
kinds of conversions you'll you'll end
up losing some data one thing to note
when you do do resampling those kinds of
things and you're lumping lots of data
together if you have numeric data
typically it will try and search for a
mean an average of all the numeric
values it showed up in that month so I
had some random numbers I threw in here
they were all latitudes and longitudes
so tried to find average lats and Long's
maybe that's not what you need you can
do other types of aggregations on these
resampled periods if you'd like so let's
take a quick look here when I do this
resampling I'm going to sample by
quarters so I'll take all thousand
records and figure out what
order of the year it showed up in and
it's gonna do a default mean lookup
right and so my latitudes and longitudes
for quarter three quarter four quarter
one all show up as averages but you
could convert these to something else
that might make sense latitudes and
longitudes if I sum them that would not
make sense but just to show you what
happens it adds them all up by all the
data is that fell within a particular
period or quarter and all the standard
kind of sums and aggregations that are
present in in pandas are available to
you whether it be you know median or
some etc you can look for first value
last value standard deviation the
maximum and the mint
we're not going to do a plot you guys
don't know how to plot so that's that
that is a whirlwind tour of a little bit
of date a little bit of time how pandas
makes life easy for you I do apologize
for those folks who wanted to come see
Chris we hope he gets better things work
out for him I do appreciate you being
here and sticking around and hanging out
with me and with that thank you for your
time and thank you for your attention
[Applause]
I'll be happy to answer questions out in
the hallway yeah sweet good question
let's let's show you where to go to get
the goods if if you want to see it okay
if you're interested I have a github
it's on Merlot all of these things are
found where they are found in my Jarvis
- tutorial I've got about 21 different
sessions that talk about things using
matplotlib using pandas to do different
things using various tools but the ones
you care about are in session 20 pandas
dates so charmelo Jarvis - sure sure
sure
that's a good question the question was
is there a way to take a floating point
number and quickly use the date/time
library to convert it into something
useful
like days months minutes and seconds off
the top of my head I don't know the
answer to that but when we get done if
we want to go out in the hallway wium
bang on the code and see we get sweet
[Applause]